remember pebble the smartwatch pioneer
that beat all the tech giants to the
punch between 2012 and 2015 pebble was
one of the most popular smart watcher
brands and they had a massive fan base
that supported them against challengers
like apple and samsung yet within just
15 months they went from being a
dominating player to being a large
player to being a laggard to shutting
down
their entire fall from glory didn't take
much longer than just a year so what
happened to pebble
taking a look back pebble wasn't some
sort of big tech company or some
billionaire's passion project pebble was
actually a startup founded by eric
mikikovsky through y combinator and
kickstarter at y combinator eric's
smartwatch idea caught the attention of
a couple of venture capitalists who
invested a total of 375 000
and though that was a solid amount it
was nowhere near enough to hire hardware
designers software engineers app
developers and everyone else involved in
creating a smart watch from scratch the
problem was that while most investors
were intrigued by the idea they weren't
willing to invest into the project
because pebble was largely a hardware
business and hardware businesses are
notorious for having razor thin profit
margins and large capital requirements
unable to convince more vcs eric decided
to take his idea to kickstarter and this
is where the brand would really take
shape tech enthusiasts on kickstarter
had no cure for the business side of
pebble they had fantasized about smart
watches for years and someone was
finally offering to make it a reality
not to mention pebbles offerings were
super cheap especially compared to
today's standards their retail price was
projected to be 150
but they were offering it for 115 to
kickstarter backers and 100 for the
first 200 backers in april of 2012 eric
launched a fundraiser with the target of
one hundred thousand dollars he would
end up raising the entire amount within
just two hours and over the next six
days pebble became the most funded
project in kickstarter's history raising
over 4.7 million dollars by the end of
the campaign pebble was able to raise
10.2 million dollars and with that they
were off to the races pebble began
working with a consulting firm called
the dragon innovation who helped them
identify suitable suppliers and
manufacturers the next several months
were not easy by any means as pebble ran
into a plethora of manufactured
difficulties and design limitations
but eric slowly addressed one issue
after another and he was eventually able
to launch the product in early 2013. the
watch was quite simple and nothing fancy
but what made the pebble watch stick out
was its insane utility pebble supported
email call and a text message
notifications and you could check stock
prices track workouts and monitor your
sleep it was basically just a standard
smart watch but in 2013 this was
phenomenal and the best part was that
since pebble opted for a minimal energy
black and white display they were able
to offer seven day battery life for 100
to 150 dollars backers were extremely
impressed and the pebble watch launched
to an uproar of positive reviews and
feedback eric didn't let this get to his
head though he was laser focused on
pushing out more applications and
improving the customer experience by
february of 2014 the pebble app store
boasted a total of 1 000 applications
but it wasn't all smooth sailing notable
players like samsung and motorola were
starting to roll out their own smart
watches so eric decided to fire back
with the second generation called the
pebble time eric had been closely
monitoring all the constructive feedback
he received on the original pebble watch
and he basically addressed every concern
with the pebble time in terms of
hardware the time offered a 64 color
display and it sported gorilla glass the
time also allowed users to swap the
stock straps with third-party straps
eric also introduced premium versions of
the time called the pebble time steel
and the pebble time round the pebble
time steel offered higher quality
finishes including steel and leather and
it offered a 10 day battery life
meanwhile the pebble time round offered
a more traditional looking watch
in february of 2015 eric once again went
to kickstarter to fund this launch and
the pebble would obliterate every record
their goal was to raise 500 000
they would reach this goal in just 17
minutes
and they would reach a million dollars
within 49 minutes
by the end of the fundraiser they raised
a total of 20 million dollars
in the meantime apple would reveal the
apple watch and the pebble fans laughed
at it apple expected people to pay 350
up to 17 dollars for a product that was
comparable to pebbles offerings not to
mention the apple watch only had a
battery life of 18 hours compared to
pebble's seven to ten day long batteries
eric was actually excited for the launch
of the apple watch he anticipated that
the apple watch would simply increase
the interest in smart watches and drive
up pebble sales and he was absolutely
right in the six months following the
release of the apple watch pebble sales
doubled they even turned down a 740
million acquisition offer from
watchmaker citizen
but just 15 months later the company
would shut down
so what in the world happened
well i think the first and biggest issue
bringing down pebble was their laser
focus on utility
from day one pebble was never trying to
produce a trendy or lifestyle product
they were trying to create the most
value-packed hardware they could
they could have easily thrown on an led
screen and cool animations but they
prioritized battery life over flashy
looks
at first this was the perfect approach
because the entire smartwatch community
was filled with a bunch of tech
enthusiasts whose primary focus was
utility
all they wanted was a long lasting
smartwatch that could display
notifications and useful information
that's it they weren't looking to flex
their watch and they couldn't care less
about what others thought about it but
as apple introduced the apple watch the
general public got involved and their
expectations were radically different
the average person buying an apple watch
doesn't actually use it for work-related
purposes
they're not tracking stocks throughout
the day and it's probably been months
since they sent their last email the top
two reasons that people buy napa watch
is for raw convenience and looks
they don't want to pull out their phone
to view text messages and they don't
want their phone checking around in
their pocket while they're working out
oh yeah and they like to see the little
activity circles fill up throughout the
day
they don't care about a seven-day
battery life and they don't want to look
at a bland display they want rich colors
and an intriguing ui and above all
whether they want to admit it or not
they want to flex
apple likes to brand themselves as a
lifestyle brand but we all know that
this just means that they're a flex
brand
now i can't really blame these guys
because i was basically describing
myself right there but this was really
bad news for pebble
the smartwatch space was rapidly growing
but all the consumers entering the space
weren't tech enthusiasts they were
general consumers who didn't really care
all that much about utility but then why
was pebble's sale skyrocketing after the
apple watch announcement
well i think that this was just an
impulse reaction to apple's crazy
pricing spending 350 to 400 on lapa
watch seemed ludicrous when there were
similar offerings for far less than half
the price
and that brings me into the second
reason behind pebble's downfall which is
a race to the bottom
after the launch of the apple watch the
number one thing that still attracted
the general public towards pebble
watches was price
other than battery life the apple watch
was slightly better than pebble's
offerings in every way
now was it twice as good not even close
but it was slightly better and it was
tied into the apple ecosystem
this resulted in people buying pebble
watches as a cheaper alternative that
offered more value per dollar
in other words the general public wasn't
buying pebble watches because they were
enthusiastic about the brand or products
they were simply settling with a pebble
watch and the worst part was that pebble
was simply encouraging people to upgrade
to an apple watch
as people wore pebble watches they
realized how convenient the smartwatch
was and the next time they bought a
smartwatch many of them decided to
splurge and spring for an apple watch so
peppa was almost serving as an
entry-level product that got people
hooked to make things even worse apple
started to be more competitive iphone
sales had hit a peak in the mid-2010s
and apple started taking diversification
much more seriously they offered much
lower entry prices and they kept older
generations around for much longer today
you can literally get a brand new apple
watch series 3 from their official
website for 200
and if you wait for black friday you can
easily pick up an apple watch for less
than 150
now of course this isn't the flagship
version but i'd be willing to bet that
most people would take an older
generation apple watch over a newer
generation pebble watch if they were
roughly the same price
so as apple brought out newer
generations it just became cheaper and
cheaper to get an apple watch
and given that price was the only thing
that attracted the general public to
pebble watches they left as soon as
apple met that need
and this was made extremely clear in the
holiday season of 2015. up until then
the release of the apple watch had been
boosting pebble sales but as soon as
apple watches were being offered for
substantial discounts throughout the
holiday season pebble sales plummeted in
the last quarter of 2015 pebble went
from doubling their sales in the last
six months to negative year-over-year
growth and let's keep in mind pebble
wasn't a profitable business
they were still in the growth phase and
they needed to achieve economies of
skill to produce sustainable
profitability if growth was slowing down
they were screwed eric tried to address
this decline in demand with the pebble 2
which debuted on kickstarter in may of
2016.
they still performed extremely well on
kickstarter but the excitement was
substantially lower than the last time
pebble was able to raise 12.7 million
dollars and while that's an insane
amount that's 40 less than last time and
for a startup that needed consistently
increasing demand this was the end eric
scrambled to find a company that could
acquire pebble but by this point
pebble's disappointing outlook was
pretty clear
the only company willing to buy pebble
was fitbit and their offer came in at
just 40 million dollars 700 million less
than just a year ago also fitbit wasn't
looking to save pebble or keep the brand
alive they were simply trying to
leverage pebble software and their team
so as soon as fitbit acquired pebble
they fired everyone except for the
software team and shut down their
company at the end of 2016 and that was
the end of pebble
honestly there wasn't really anything
that pebble could have done that much
better
sure they could have tended to the
desires of the general public but i
don't think that would have played out
much better either
pebble's monumental growth was thanks to
a lack of options along with great
execution by eric but the truth is no
level of execution could have
overpowered apple in the mid-2010s truly
a sad ending to a spectacular start
do you guys own an apple watch and if so
why do you choose apple over the
competition comment that down below also
drop a like if you think that pebble
will always be the og and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you